-Our next guest
is the Super Bowl-winning
former head coach
of the Pittsburgh Steelers
and a member of the
Pro Football Hall of Fame.
His memoir, "Heart and Steel,"
is available now.
Please welcome to the show
Bill Cowher.
Coach Cowher, I -- Look.
I'm just going to be honest.
I'm really excited you're here.
-Hey, Seth,
I didn't get the dress code.
Was I supposed to wear
a tank top?
I don't know. I wasn't sure.
-No, this is for the best.
I think we managed
to hammer that home.
-Okay.
-So, this is a really cool thing
that you were inducted
into the hall of fame,
but because of the pandemic,
you're actually going to get
to the ceremony this August.
Have you gotten to at least
put on the gold jacket yet?
-I have put on the gold jacket.
I got it earlier.
It fit perfectly.
My number on the inside is 331.
So, forever, I'll be number 331
in the Canton
Pro Football Hall of Fame,
as I sit in there with my bust.
It's a team
I can't get cut from, Seth.
I'm on it
for the rest of my life.
-You know, this is --
I knew a fair amount
about your career,
but I really enjoyed
reading the book.
One of the most
fascinating things to me --
you were playing football,
you know, you had been,
obviously, plagued by injuries
to some degree.
But you were still
an active football player
when you decided to take less
money and get into coaching.
Obviously,
that worked out for you,
but that must have been
an incredible leap of faith
to make as a young guy.
-Yeah, it really was.
If you looked through the book,
Seth, I was probably more public
than I've ever been in doing so.
And as I sat down
with this book,
I talked about --
it's not just a football book.
It's about football, family,
and one's life journey
of lessons learned.
And along the way, I had to make
a lot of those decisions
we all have to make when you
reach that fork in the road.
Yogi Berra says,
"Just take it."
I think you've got to
put some thought into it.
So, I was given an opportunity
by Marty Schottenheimer
to go with him,
to get into coaching,
and I never looked back.
-As you mentioned,
this isn't just a football book.
It's really a beautiful book
about family.
You talk about
the wonderful family you have,
as well as some really
difficult loss.
Your father, your wife
both passed away
in a really small
period of time.
Was it hard to go back
and write those stories down?
-It really was.
I mean, I sat there and had to
find the perfect collaborator
to write that with,
and I got Michael Holley.
And he was that.
He was able to pull
more stories out of me
than a licensed therapist,
to be quite honest with you.
We sat there and talked about
how we're going to
write this book, and he said,
"Let's just do it
chronologically."
So, as I sat down and went
through the periods of time
in my life --
as you talk about growing up
in Pittsburgh,
going back to Pittsburgh,
playing in the National
Football League,
then coaching in
the National Football League,
the reason I stepped down,
got into TV,
and then, as you stated,
in 2010, a period of time
where I lost my father
and my wife
within three months'
period of time,
I found myself laughing,
crying, smiling,
and just thinking and reflecting
on a lot of things
that took place in my life
and the mentors
are a big part of it --
that being Marty Schottenheimer,
Dan Rooney, and my father.
And, really,
the women in my life,
as well,
have been a big part of it.
Because I have three daughters,
my beautiful wife
that passed away, Kaye,
and my current wife today, V.
-You talk about the fact,
you know,
you grew up in Pittsburgh,
everyone around you was
a Pittsburgh Steelers fan.
You're 34 years old when you get
the head-coaching job,
you know, which is so --
when you think about it now,
so incredibly young to
take on that responsibility.
You have a great story in
the book about a season ending
and going out to dinner,
and your dad kind of forgetting
that you were the actual coach
of the Steelers at the time.
-It was. It was at the end
of the '92 season.
And you remember the '92 season.
Neil O'Donnell got hurt.
I put Bubby Brister in for,
like, the last five games.
And Bubby played better
as we went on, right?
Neil got ready.
We had a bye week.
And I thought a player
never loses his job to injury.
So Neil came in
and played the playoff game
against the Buffalo Bills.
It was not one
of his better games.
The next weekend, we go over
to my dad's house in Crafton,
the same place we always
had Sunday afternoon dinners.
My brothers are there,
my kids are there,
everybody takes
their place at a seat.
And it's kind of hectic.
Things are going on.
My dad gets up out of his seat,
goes over and gets a beer
out of the kitchen,
and he goes,
"How about them Steelers?
How dumb were them to sit there
and start Neil O'Donnell?
He hadn't played in a month,
and Bubby Brister
is getting better and better."
I go, "Dad."
He goes, "What?"
"Them Steelers?"
I go, "That was me,
your son,
that made that decision."
He kind of stopped and he goes,
"Well, I'm sure you had
a good reason for it."
Didn't even ask me.
I was just like, "Okay.
I guess I was wrong again."
Then he went on
to another subject.
I thought, "Wow.
You'll never take the fan
out of Pittsburghers."
-Well, you know, my father --
that's why I love the Steelers
as much as I do.
And I was talking to him
about this book,
and I said I don't know
if this is healthy or not,
but there are games
that when Bill writes
about them in the book,
I think that if I wrote
my autobiography,
I would actually have more pages
about the game.
That's how traumatic
it was for me.
Is it -- When you look
back at your career,
do you remember the wins more
or the losses more?
-Seth, I remember every
AFC Championship loss.
And I know you were actually
at the '94 Championship loss
that we had against
the San Diego Chargers.
Do you remember
the temperature that day?
-I remember it was very cold.
-No, it was very warm.
It was like 60 degrees.
-Oh, I think I meant that my
heart got very cold at the end.
-[ Laughs ] It was 60 degrees
in the middle of January.
We're playing
the San Diego Chargers.
That was a bad -- I just thought
that's a bad omen to start with.
And we got down to it,
and the bottom line is,
we had a chance to throw
the ball into the end zone
to win the championship
and go down --
and go try to win
one for the thumb.
It fell incomplete.
The San Diego Chargers
go to the Super Bowl.
And that happens
to be the same year
that I had my 20th
high-school class reunion.
And I go back to my 20th
high-school class reunion,
head coach
of the Pittsburgh Steelers.
And I'm sitting there
thinking, okay,
we came off a pretty good
season, in a championship game,
three straight years
in the playoffs.
What are we going to do
when we have the reunion?
I think I'll just do a --
just run by, stop in, stop out.
We're going to do it
on a cruise.
I go, "A what?"
"A cruise."
So we get on this boat.
It's going to be a boat.
The boat takes off.
Now I'm on a river cruise for
three hours with all the guys
I went to high school with,
all telling me the things
I did wrong
in the San Diego Charger game,
asking for tickets
for the next year.
And I'm thinking,
"I can't get off this boat."
So I had to be very nice
to everybody
and cordial with everybody.
I'm like, "Yeah, you're right."
"Absolutely right."
"I should have thought
about that."
"Yeah, you told me that
back in high school, yep."
-[ Laughs ]
I certainly, you know --
I was with my family when you
won the Super Bowl in 2005.
It's one of my favorite
moments with my family.
Obviously, you got to celebrate
it with your family, too.
Does it make it easier,
looking back at your tenure
in Pittsburgh
because you did get to bring
the Lombardi back?
-Yeah, it did.
It meant so much to me, Seth,
to be able to hand that trophy
to Dan Rooney,
you know, after 14 years,
because he had entrusted
so much faith in me
and stayed with me through
a lot of difficult times
and a lot of
disappointing losses.
I talk about the '94 game,
'97 against the Denver Broncos,
2001 against
the New England Patriots,
and then 2004,
just the year before,
against the Patriots again.
And we finally tried to get
there and get over the hump
and then get over the hump
and go back
and then be able to hand that
to Mr. Rooney
was one of
the most gratifying --
I would say the most
gratifying moment in my career.
-I feel as though once a coach
leaves Pittsburgh,
especially someone
who is local like you,
you are now only
looked back on with love.
You are a beloved figure
in Pittsburgh.
But in the time
that you were there,
even though
you were a local kid,
even though your teams
had a lot of success,
is it true that you had
a different way of getting gas
during the season
and out of season?
-Yes, it is.
You know, the longer
you stay in Pittsburgh,
you find out that people
get closer to you.
You start to build
a little bit of a friendship.
And then people feel like
they can feel very comfortable
giving you advice
and start telling you the things
that can help you
get over the hump.
"I know exactly
what you need to do."
So it got to the point where --
you know what?
If I had to stop and get gas,
I waited --
If we won, I got gas that week
during the day.
Not a problem.
"Hey, Coach, great game."
If we lost, I learned to get gas
at night and go to self-serve.
I'd get there
and pull my hat down.
I didn't need to hear
about all the things
that we should've been doing
and the things we didn't do.
So, yes, I was actually --
I was kind of just
acclimating my lifestyle
to whether we'd win or lose.
-Last thing, "Cahr Pahr" --
For people who aren't
from Pittsburgh,
they'll probably think
those are just nonsense words.
Do you want to tell
everybody what Cahr Pahr is?
-Well, "Cahr" is, like,
another way
for a Pittsburgher,
kind of a Yinzer --
Like, yinz, Cowher --
"Hey, Cahr."
You know, like, Cowher Power.
"Yeah, it's Cahr Pahr Hour."
We don't pronounce our words --
That's one of the things
I had to get over
going into TV, Seth,
was learning how
to enunciate words again.
-Well, you've done
a very fine job with it,
and you've written
a very fine book.
Really, really appreciate
the time.
Thanks so much
for being here, Coach.
-Thanks for having me, Seth.
-"Heart and Steel"
is available everywhere now,
but please remember to support
local and independent
bookstores.